aujourd'hui on a quatre personnes de
plus qui sont infectés au coronavirus
donc pour un total de 21
on à 853 personnes qui sont sous
investigation
c'est important de dire aussi qu'on à
1399 personnes qui ont été testées et
qui ont reçu un résultat négatif
aujourd'hui je veux vraiment envoyer un
message sur les personnes âgées sur les
haies ni parce que les personnes âgées
sont beaucoup plus à risque de
conséquences graves
alors que les personnes plus jeunes je
veux un peu comme rassurer incluant les
personnes qui ont été infectées la
grande majorité des personnes plus
jeunes qui ont été infectés vont s'en
sortiront pas de conséquences graves et
je veux partager avec vous les données
qu'on a vécu en chine parce qu'il demain
en chine on a vécu avant nous les
situations donc on peut profiter de ces
données là donc en chine quand on
regarde par catégorie d'âge les taux de
décès des personnes infectées
chez les 30-39 ans c'est 0,2 pour ça
donc moins d'un pour cent chez les 40-49
ans c'est 0,4 pour cent chez les 50-59
ans c'est 1,3 pour cent chez les 60-69
ans 3,6 pour cent et l'on voit l'or chez
les 70 79 ans ces 8 % de décès des
personnes infectées et chez les
personnes qui ont plus de 81 ses 14 8%
des décès chez les personnes qui sont
infectées donc comme vous le voyez les
personnes plus jeunes
les restes sont très faibles donc
jeux comme rassurer les personnes plus
jeunes même si vous êtes infecté les
risques de conséquences graves sont très
faibles mais faucon comme société qu'on
soit capable de tout faire pour protéger
nos personnes qui sont plus âgés
donc aujourd'hui je veux demander à
toutes les personnes qui sont âgés de 70
ans et plus d'éviter de sortir de chez
eux
donc pendant un certain nombre de
semaines jusqu au contraire de demander
à toutes les personnes au québec qui ont
plu qui ont soixante dix ans au plus de
ne pas sortir à moins que ce soit
vraiment la nécessaire de rester chez
elle j'annonce souci aujourd'hui que
tout livre visites dans les centres de
personnes arrivent dans les hôpitaux
vont maintenant être interdit ce qu'on
veut c'est évidemment limiter les
risques de contagion donc il éviter que
des personnes se présentent dans les
centres de personnes âgées dans les
hôpitaux vienne infecter les personnes
âgées passer ce qui est notre plus grand
risque au québec
évidemment aussi je profité de
l'occasion pour répéter aux personnes
que c'est pas une bonne idée de voyager
à l'étranger
peu importe large que vous avez 4
regarde actuellement les 21 corps de
québécois qui ont été infectés ces
personnes jeunes hommes les pays ont été
infectées aux états unis en france en
italie en iran en république dominicaine
en inde et sur des bateaux de croisière
donc comme vous voyez un peu partout
dans le monde
il ya très peu de pays qui sont épargnés
pour cela que j'exhorte les québécois de
ne pas voyager à l'étranger bon flic et
des visiteurs étrangers
j'ai parlé hier à monsieur
trudeau je vais lui reparler aujourd'hui
mais je continue à penser que c'est
urgent de réduire le nombre de visiteurs
étrangers au canada puis là dessus le
docteur arruda est très claire bon je
vous dis évidemment là je vois les gens
qui travaillent très fort entre autres
la ministre de la santé son équipe
ce qu'on essaie de faire d'abord c'est
d'avoir le plus de cliniques possible
pour tester donc actuellement une cette
clinique désigné dans les prochains
jours vont ajouter 12 donc au en avoir
dix neuf ce qu'on essaie aussi de faire
une grande priorité de la collaboration
du conseil du trésor puis des différents
ministères concernés
c'est d'augmenter le nombre de lits donc
d'avoir des lits dans des locaux
temporaires le plus rapidement possible
évidemment aussi une clé importante et
probablement le plus important c'est nos
anges gardiens c'est tout ce toutes
celles qui travaillent dans le réseau de
la santé
j'ai demandé demain à rencontrer les
représentants les représentants
syndicaux des employés infirmières
préposés médecin pour essayer de voir ce
qu'on peut faire ensemble pour les aider
bon évidemment voir ce qu'on peut faire
aussi avec la négociation qui est en
cours avec la rémunération donc je vais
demain les rencontrer pour en discuter
donc on a un peu un espèce de course
contre la montre et pour freiner le
virus il faut agir vite faut prendre des
décisions très rapidement
c'est pour ça qu'il faut mettre un peu
de côté les règles ordinaires
hier soir g20 conseil des ministres pour
que le gouvernement adopte un décret
pour déclarer l'état d'urgence sanitaire
sur tout le territoire québécois
l'objectif de ce décret
c'est d'être capable d'abord le décret
est bon pour une durée de 10 jours mais
peut être renouvelable par la suite
l'idée c'est d'avoir des mesures
exceptionnelles qu'on est capable de
mettre en place rapidement je vous donne
quelques exemples tous les achats ça
soit pour les lits pour les médicaments
pour tout ce qu'ils ont besoin la
ministre de la santé d'ailleurs le
décret donne ses pouvoirs à la ministre
de la santé donc être capable de
procéder sans appel d'offres donc être
capable de faire les achats rapidement
être capable aussi d'ajuster certaines
mesures par exemple les médecins demandé
que l'avenir
la ramq upei pour les actes qui sont
faites par téléconférence
donc ça va maintenant être possible
daniel va avoir ce pouvoir là on essaie
aussi de ramener des infirmiers qui
étaient retraités dans les réseaux ou
simple que dire
il y en a qui hésitaient à cause de leur
cotisation à l'ordre infirmier benon
voter on n'aurait plus besoin n'auront
plus besoin de payer leur cotisation à
l'ordre des infirmières donc ces gens de
pouvoir
c'est important de donner un daniel pour
agir rapidement terminant même vous dire
d'abord toutes les équipes dans toutes
les meubles et les ministères sont
mobilisés je pense entre autres à
l'éducation du ministère de la famille
on travaille très fort avec la santé
pour que les personnes qui travaillent
dans le réseau de la santé qui ont
besoin de services de garde les consos
capable de leur offrir en contre temps
de faire un inventaire puis on travaille
autant du côté des services de garde que
des écoles je veux aussi vous dire
évidemment la priorité c'est la santé
mais je comprends très bien les impacts
économiques qu'on voit dans les
prochains jours annoncer des mesures
d'abord pour les individus que l'on veut
s'arrimer avec le gouvernement fédéral
parce que il ya des personnes qui ont
droit à l'assurance-emploi
deux des personnes qui ont pas le droit
à l'assurance
emploi donc nous notre objectif là c'est
qu'on soit capable de compenser
financièrement ceux qui auraient besoin
d'un petit zoo les qui est pas
d'incitatif l'aller est obligé de
prendre le risque d'infecter d'autres
personnes sur les lieux de travail
j'ai écrit ce très bien aussi que des
entreprises pour qui c'est très
difficile je pense encore tout le
secteur de la culture
les travailleurs autonomes donc pierre
fait ce qu'il est en train de travailler
encore là que le gouvernement fédéral
ont à cette série mais il la bd c'est
qu'ils vont annoncer des mesures mais on
voudrait simplifier la vie aux
entreprises aux travailleurs autonomes
pour pas qu'ils aient besoin d'aller
cogner trop de portes donc être capable
de bien s'arrimer ça va être annoncé
dans les prochains jours mais évidemment
là la priorité des priorités c'est la
santé bon j'ai parlé tantôt aux trois
chefs de l'opposition
je les remercie d'ailleurs pour leur
collaboration va besoin deux autres du
côté budgétaire voit aussi bon ce qu'on
fait avec les travaux à l'assemblée
nationale donc je termine en vous disant
je comprends très bien que les décisions
qu'on annonce ça peut créer un espèce de
sentiment d'angoissé dans population
mais moi je veux dire aux québécois ce
qu'on fait rapidement ses pots justement
yves tlp c'est de prendre tout de mettre
toutes les chances de notre côté pour
que le virus se propage le moins
rapidement possible puis au moins deux
personnes ne possède donc a pas de
raison de paniquer mouche convaincu
qu'ensemble on est capable pour voir
passer au travail merci